I don't even know.
Very spontaneous, it just happens as it goes, I guess.
I can be in a routine though.
So typically for me, it's work, nine to whenever I get off, I guess.
And sometimes I'll go out, and then other times, I'll just go home...
...because I don't feel like going out.
And then on the weekends, that's when I come back to life.
So there's a thing called "cuffing season."
And that's when basically it gets cold outside, and you don't really want to be out late...
...because the sun goes down early, and you just want to be at home.
You don't want to be home by yourself,...
...so you get with someone and I guess, you kind of hibernate with them in a way.
So my relationships seem a little short.
I'm not proud to admit that, but I don't know why.
I think it's because I'm always busy, I'm always on the go,...
...so I don't really give them as much attention as I probably should.
But I'm getting a little older and a little bit more mature,...
...so I think I'm starting to be able to like, balance work life and having fun...
...and being like, serious and committed.
So hopefully this season, I'll change.